[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a huit jours aujourd'hui les
roulants de la sncf débrayé pour 36
heures essentiellement il revendiquait
il revendique toujours d'ailleurs de
meilleures conditions de travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est trente six heures de grève nous
les avons vécues avec un seul cheminots
il s'appelle pierre quand est il à 24
ans il est chauffeur sur une locomotive
à vapeur au mans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un gréviste convaincu mais il aime
tellement sa machine qu'elle est devenu
pour lui une personne
[Musique]
11 est venue cette passion sa venue
depuis très longtemps
quand j'étais gosse souvent quand je
pouvais monter là dessus sur une petite
ligne
ouais je monte avec les gars sur la
machine des puits alors évidemment le
pire aux grandes la petite machine de
manoeuvre on est passé aux plus grosses
machines
c'est bien qu'on a fini à faire des
express comme celle et vous aviez la
possibilité de monter sur des machines
dans ce métier enfin la possibilité
d'apprendre avec les gaffes parce que
les gars évidemment le conte produire un
cantique vol un gosse qui s'intéressent
moi même ça m'est arrivé de trouver un
gosse qui s'intéressait voir une machine
mais on peut pas lui refuser
c'est interdit par le règlement on peut
pour lui refuse
ça m'est arrivé à tours une fois y avait
un petit gosse il avait 7 ans et
regarder ça et avec sa grand mère est
alors le pilote si nous a demandé si
vous pouvez voir dedans alors là du
monde à logos quand il est redescendu
sous lequel voulait plus partir c'était
ou si on lui avait donné parce que la
lune oui il faut avoir fait ça pour le
comprendre douillet et puisque ça de
vivant qu'est ce que vous trouvez qu'est
ce qui est vivant dans une machine à 9
heures et qui n'est pas dans une machine
à vapeur déjà d'un par sa coupe c'est
ces travaux alors il ya des machinistes
et les grands dialogues finition
vous avez les rcd machine machine
américaine
c'est rap us est costaud s'arracherait
n'importe quoi côté de ça vous avez des
pacifiques ces deux pc des grandes roues
machine express c'est l'élégance et ses
comparables
un homme une femme et c'est la force
l'autre celle en bouteille il ya cette
impression de force qu'on retrouve dans
dans les vielles dans les vallées garder
des pistons enfin évidemment les puits
sont les voix révélées les tiges de
piston qui rendent qui sortent ça fait
un peu comme un moteur de voiture qu'ils
seraient ouverts alors que sur un engin
moderne vous avez rien de tout ça ça
veut dire ou qui tourne c'est tout me
suis l'électrique ne retrouverez pas ça
non pas par trouver ça faut pas le
retrouver sur un engin
parce que vous êtes enfermé dans une
cave in ne sentais rien vous ne voyez
rien enfin si la voix devant vous qui se
déroule c'est tout alors que sur une
vapeur la voix vous l'aviez même pas
vous voyez les côtés de la machine
c'est tout à fait différent
essayez de faire corps avec la machine
voulu parler qu est ce que tu as envie
avec commun une personne qu avec son
chien ou avec son chapeau c'est à gaza
mais pourtant avant que vous aviez
désormais je me suis mais je crois que
maintenant vous n'avez plus la même
chine vous changez de me suis dit oui je
m'en charge la machine tous les jours on
a perdu deux c'est une partie de notre
travail qui s'en va c'est une partie de
l'intérêt alors évidemment ça nous
rapproche maintenant des conducteurs
d'engins moderne on a vu ce sentiment
d'avoir quelque chose à sauver alors
qu'elle et vient dans le temps avait
vraiment ce sentiment là ils étaient
titulaires des deux machines c'était
presque les propriétaires la machine on
leur prêtait évidemment puisqu'il est en
chemin de fer on est quoi causer de leur
machine c'était notre machine c'était
poids pour la machinerie aux poupées
alors que maintenant c'est ça tombe on
en trouve encore quelques semaines le
titulaire mais plus beaucoup vous
aimeriez beaucoup avoir encore une fine
avoue un compagnon
libre et surtout une machine est un
compagnon
ça fait une équipe c'est sa forme à un
taux de 3 personnes
chacun a son rôle à jouer sur cage au
sol des deux gars jouent leur la machine
aussi parce qu'une machine c'est
qu'appréciez vous savez c'est
capricieuse a son petit caractère
un jour ça va très bien maintenant ça va
être vraiment et vous arrivez à lire son
caractère à suivre tout c'est ce que la
machine russe un bon on le ressent
évidemment par le fait on ne ressent
même temps qu'elle
enfin quand on lance en point avant l on
le ressent après parce que si votre
feuille pourri il est foutu
évidemment c'est bio en santé après
alors il faut sentir ses avants pour
l'éviter mécaniciens qui sont une bielle
qui chauffe il faut qu'il a soignés
avant de briller qu'est ce que vous
allez ressentir quand vous allez quitter
votre machine dernière fois vous allez
quitter définitivement sur quoi je peux
pas vous le dire encore puisqu'elle la
question ne s'est pas encore posé que
vous êtes vous y pensez sérieux qu'un
jour vous allez vous quitter je le sais
où ils ont malheureusement pour
l'instant plus grand mal c'est de les
voir procès schalit bout c'est que quand
vous voyez une machine que vous avez
connues même sans avoir roulé dessus
enfin c'est toujours une machine jean du
jour au lendemain on la coupe c'est fini
la machine
il a fallu des presque des moins pour la
construire et puis en deux jours c'est
elle est réduite à un tas de ferraille
elle a perdu tout
ça c'est un peu comme quelqu'un qu'on
enterre
il reste que les souvenirs c'est sous
les bons et les mauvais tout ça ça fait
des bons souvenirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que c'est se lisent par disque
bruitages de train à traction d'un train
reliant mode de traction
puis alors un peu de machines wever et
vous pourrez y admirer votre machine pas
tout à fait puisque c'est pas encore ça
ne s'est pas seul c'est ça pour été fait
par rien que pour la machine s'était
fait pour le train les voyageurs on est
pro tellement la machine parce qu'on en
parle a accompagné un petit cheval
qu'est ce que c'est dish veulent c'est
le compresseur qu'il faut un univers
pour alimenter les produits général et
les charmes
on
[Musique]
thérèse
et
et comme ça sur l'avant oui ça plaît
c'est cette impression vous retrouver là
puis à peu près
[Musique]
et là qu'est ce que c'est
ben là c'est le train qui roule
dans la moto non c'est sur un lagon à
une moitié royal sûrs tous s'entendaient
pas ça j'en entends pas le même rythme
la nuit on peut dire c'est le silence
relatif silence n'entend pas ce
spectacle sur les
on
non n'entend pas comme ça nous menacer
c'est un bout et prolongée nous toujours
c'est un bruit de fond on à la salle de
l'écartement entre les bougies du manoir
[Musique]
vous préférez entendre le bruit de la
machine qui va leur ouïe la machine on
entend plus s'il fait les amagou mais
c'est pas du tout paris
[Musique]
ya beaucoup de bruit dans votre machine
c'est les bons seront faits si on purge
à niveau nos ça fait dur oui si on fait
le grand écart en charge et la machine
mettez donc
non mais enfin non le bruit de la paix
lui tape sur le gunner
trop mon jeu
si l'on s'entend ap l'iran genre ont peu
après après 8h et 10h
à
alors mentionné ci-haut flamand trucs et
des planches
j'entendais beaucoup de vent ou de l'air
fait voter bourillon de machines sait
pas qui fait du bruit c'est qu'on le
sent pas mal oui quand on a le vent de
face ça va loin de aussi alors le vent
de côté s'engouffre sous la bruine
ça fait pas mal de bruit les débrouillés
puis andré l'effroi
et s
je ne buvais mon instant qui passe me
colle aux études tout ça c'est du chemin
de fer mais c'est je me fais un voyage
ces bonus bancaires d'hôtes
ah c'est le chemin de fer du voyageur ça
c'est pour le sepa nature mannix
les bus et brouillard les apports
tout s'y fait croiser un autre
mais là encore les vitrages
les émeutes en france
qu'est ce que c'est là ça commence à
molly on arrivait sur india s'est
ralenti ça diminue individus
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est
c'est le mécanicien chauffeur qu'elle
désire s ils n ont jamais gagné un sur
deux qui font attention puis alors le
chauffeur quand des chiens au sein de
son groupe et sur les arrêts
je refais raïs occupe de sa flotte de
son feu de la fumée profil mais envers
le petit coup de sifflet comme ça c'est
des foyers petit bonjour encore 5,4
[Musique]
la grève fait perdre combien sur scène
4000 5000 6000 ça dépend la catégorie
des roulements d'être un fait ça c'est
pas mal ça présente sur un salaire de 85
à 90 milles francs ça commence à
apparaître
surtout quand on fait la grève deux fois
dans le mot presque trop puisqu'on a
fait la dernière le 28 février
ça paraît avec à mettre les deux buts à
bout ça fait déjà presque dix mille
francs et vos trouvailles et se montre
combien 25000 ici
bref
si vous avez déjà pris des vacances non
nous n'avons porté de vacances parce que
ne pouvant pas c'est impossible donc
sera amené à faire d'autres actions
syndicales corps obligatoirement oui
parce que maintenant von arx on a
attaqué on attaque et on peut dire ferme
ça fait la troisième en 1 pour un mot il
faut pu s'arrêter maintenant
maintenant c'est marche ou crève mais il
faut les les pousser jusqu'au bout de
nos actions pour obtenir le maximum de
leno réclamant sinon parce que ça ce
sera trois actions foutu pour rien
le produit est ce qui est un peu et du
moment 10 entre votre amour du métier et
votre action scénique
non il n'y a pas de contradiction c'est
fort ça ne va pas entendre oui ça fait
ça fait trois jours j'ai pas mis les
pieds dessus ça commençait apparaît un
peu gauche si l'on regarde la droite
nous actons c'est comme dans les chemins
de fer il ya deux classes les premières
les deuxièmes et intrigues inadmissible
pourquoi avoir de classe c'est vrai tout
le monde en tout le monde n'est tout le
monde est égal
tout le monde est dans la même tenue
on part tous à zéro des mêmes principes
[Musique]
alors deux classes y en ait deux pour
moi des clubs en france et à la classe
de ceux qui travaillent quels que soient
leur travail et la clause de ce qui
profite à celui travail c'est tout alors
après il ya un espèce de petit centre on
peut appeler ça la ville pour choisir
alors elle elle est condamnée si l'un
des deux est fausse complètement dans
les premières places ou à raison les
deuxièmes alors pour moi la deuxième
place c'est les plus lointaines dans les
trains et tout ça ça représente la
gauche un à gauche ça peut représenter
si bien avec lui aurait car la
communiste vivre ce moment fait la
collection la collection de cela non
parce que je la scène un baume pour moi
c'est un bonhomme et il a écrit ce qu'il
pensait il est avec lui en avance sur
son temps comme comme je lui en ai un
peu avec la science fiction
il a vraiment les cris et gratte au
point de kenzo à part des différences
les différences de détails et on
pourrait reporter ça exactement dans les
pauvres oui
cadets germinal avec les grèves des
mineurs mettez les crs à la place des
gardes nationaux c'est pareil la cote
est ouverte avec un fusil de l'autre
côté les veillées étape dans la dèche en
gros ça veut dire quoi le charbon puis
c'est tout cet été les mêmes termes
évidemment on a eu des acquisitions sur
les ouvriers des du 19e siècle on a eu
des congés payés on a eu les assurances
sociales audel sécurité sociale tout
seul ses formes est ma seule mais
puisqu'on y est on est parti on a réussi
à avoir ce petit à petit je vois
pourquoi là la machine s'arrêtera pas
est-ce qu'il avait mené actuellement
c'est une bonne vie est ce que
heureuse une vie heureuse sont plus
heureuses que certains qui habitent avec
nous à allonnes sans aucun doute parce
qu'ils sont bien plus malheureux tout
enfin une vie heureuse pour être
meilleur qu'est ce que ce sera une
virose un peu plus de temps à la maison
un peu plus de loisirs alors un peu plus
de loisirs
ça a l'air un peu plus élevé et puis les
dimanches ce plu dimanche enfin tout ça
ça fait partie de nos revendications
mais je la passe après la fin de mon
gosse mais pour bien loin derrière et
quand litres et la vapeur je quitterai
la vapeur alors là je sais pas qu'est ce
que ça donnera peut-être un type et gris
tu peux voir vous dire encore
samedi midi la grève est finie
[Musique]
pire quand elle retourne au dépôt il va
signer sa feuille de route il va
retrouver sa machine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]